my name is my Deezer and I have a
doctorate in computer science at the University
of Montreal
in my research group we are
interested in the intersection
between artificial intelligence so
machine learning models
methods trained in computer science  and
tools that have been developed
for Algeria
but it's obvious that Mila it's no
secret there it's an internationally renowned institute
so there are
researchers of all expertise we
can collaborate with so many
people  on the spot but above all what
came to me were the
humanist values ​​leaving them
diversity inclusion openness collaboration
so all that is really things
that mattered to me for my workplace
it is a  research community which
is so vibrant in addition Montreal
is great for the quality of life then
you are not expected